we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
uh here is a caller who is Bravely
engaged in fighting the war on Christmas
which doesn't exist okay let's take a
listen
David sir this is James hope you had a
good Hanukkah thank you
um I wanted to talk to you about uh the
issue of the war on Christmas Yes
um
with maybe one exception I've never
actually heard of anyone get offended
uh when someone says Merry Christmas but
I can't tell you how many uh right
Wingers I've heard get offended by happy
holidays um
I think it's time that that the
progressives really really called the
Republicans out on their on their you
know wokeness and their
um their policing speech someone says
happy holidays and they go why aren't
you saying Merry Christmas to me you're
by happy holidays I mean they really are
snowflakes it's happy holidays
triggers them that much
um
but yeah hardly anyone I've I make
actually gets offended by Merry
Christmas
anyway I hope you have a good rest of
your holiday season and uh
hope to hear from you soon yeah so
listen
um I I tweeted the other day and some
people got so mad at me I I was serious
when I tweeted it but it's not like some
big thing when people say happy holidays
to me around this time of year I go
happy holidays yeah and if they say
Merry Christmas I say oh happy Hanukkah
it's just like it's not a big deal I'm
not doing it aggressively it's just if
they wish me Merry Christmas because
that's what they celebrate I wish them
happy Hanukkah because that's what I
celebrate it's not a big deal no one has
ever gotten upset no one has ever gotten
offended it's it's kind of a joke but I
I do do that do that I'm not offended
nobody's offended it's really not a big
deal the thing that really does seem to
offend people
is these right Wingers when they are
told happy holidays they believe they
are being told happy holidays because
some woke Marxist leftists Obama yeah
like Obama or whoever right
has pressured uh a worker at Best Buy
to forego Merry Christmas and instead to
say happy holidays so it is true I don't
get wish me Happy Kwanzaa I don't care
wish me whatever you want and then I'll
respond however I want no one's offended
we're having conversations it's fine
okay but the people who get offended are
the ones wished happy holidays when they
believe they should be wished Merry
Christmas and it's pathetic we have a
great bonus show for you today
this it's unbelievable that this even
happened
at least 27 people are dead in Buffalo
New York because of a snowstorm
okay we're going to talk about the
horrifying situation in Buffalo
Adidas much less seriously Adidas is
scrambling to sell over 500 million
dollars worth of Yeezys after cutting
ties with Kanye West
uh where what are they going to do with
them where are they going to end up it's
an interesting place by the way where
sometimes uh clothing and shoes end up
when they are no longer sold on the
retail Market we'll talk about that and
a new poll finds that Arizona now
independent Senator Kirsten Cinema would
get crushed if she ran as an independent
in 2024 which was supposedly one of the
considerations in her moving from
Democrat to Independent all of those
stories and so much more all on today's
bonus show how do you get the bonus show
you sign up at joinpakman.com oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
yes everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad well depends how
you're making that money Alex that's the
truth we're offering nothing other than
a good time with the award-winning bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code please no
more Trump and you have to say it that
way when you enter it please no more
Trump we'll see you on the bonus show in
mere moments